welcome to this video playing Parma pill
from Estonia
let's see going to play quickly him no
he's taking his sweet time
finally yeah and have not played him
before I I'm surprised how often this
still happens that you play M players
you haven't faced before I can't come on
let's let's have some let's have some
funny with the trucks alone I really
don't know at the opening if he takes on
f7 with the night I just know that I
take on f2 and and hope for the best
check ok it seems that he's also not not
not knowing it - great I mean this is a
good line Bishop f7 this is this much I
know but he takes he takes a while to to
make those move switches somewhat yeah
this good news that is not dashing odd
moves and refuting everything quickly
yeah I guess maybe h6 and Bishop g4 is
it some it's a problematic thing for for
white okay so should I do this with aged
six and we should reform I can also play
Bishop g4 right here awesome what does
not look too bad I mean there are there
are funny ideas here like the Queen
moves Bishop e2 yeah all you needs to go
here so h6 m
I certainly don't mind to take the night
if it goes back and age 6hg okay maybe
just go back
yeah what a weird position now with the
King on his seven this is really a
opening for for a special persons I
don't don't normally play this of course
just just for fun the end blitz okay I'm
going to take it and now trying to get
at the energy for upon you can also take
here but that's not a good idea
327 f3 I may be taken I may be taking on
the form
hmm really don't know what you should
play yeah yes it's a total mess maybe
Queenie chew or something trying to get
queens off with a dick I don't really
think I that black is in bad shape I
mean I have everything developed yeah
including the king if you want mm-hmm
check okay
well this looks what taking with the
rook it's both possible taking with the
rook seems seems more more aggressive
yeah maybe 94 maybe it's this 94 if he
takes the Queen that's a check medium if
he takes on d4 Bishop takes rook F to
rook f3 as a funny way to win
yeah then this is winning up he takes
Knight f3 double check King edge mangu
KJ checkmate in two moves check and this
is a funny double pin which should which
should really win the game
white forfeits due to disconnection yeah
it did win the game even maybe it was a
bit wasn't amused up this game yeah it's
it's the truck slur what can you do it
always leads to this this kind of
strange strange situations I don't know
I don't really know how to how to judge
this and it's just terribly complicated
I mean I'm I'm pretty certain that it
should be somehow okay for black here
because I've I have everything in play
all my pieces are in play
so I don't think it should be it should
be terrible or something computer wants
to go 8-4 with an advantage for white fo
and then 92 there now it's it's going a
bit down this is this is very dangerous
though yeah - to already check oh this
is a Winningham like black is - 7 - 8
okay hmm
yeah and that's not this big surprise I
mean I have half a pieces in that tech
and basically a screen edge for okay
Jade hard to defend and f3 needs - what
happened in the game 94 in the win yeah
this this mate should be Jack should be
looked at Jack just always nice to check
mate nice to look at and there's also
this may check if you wonder chatter
native check mate it's also very cute
and I mean he needed to take a hike
Andrew care 3 and now black wins the
house just look f2 bishop f2 whatever
that's a double pin here on the rook end
upon so yeah that's that's the nice
thing about openings that's like the
Traxler it you can lose terribly but if
you win it will very often be a be quite
nice okay well thanks for watching